Hi there, I'm Jasha Klebe,
and I'm the composer for
the Netflix series Animal.
Today,
I'd like to share with you
one of my personal
favourite moments
in the octopus episode
and how I crafted the music.
I set the scene
by characterising the ocean
with a wash
of ambient guitars
and swirling synths
and organs.
Creating
this rippling motion,
that provides
a sense of mystery
as we descent deeper.
Just as the octopus eggs
come into frame,
I signify them
with these flickering
sonar-type sounds.
I wanted to convey
these little bursts of life
that are just waiting
to hatch.
It's here I introduce
a long melodic whistle
that becomes
a signature sound
for a giant pacific octopus.
There's a familiarity
and intimacy
to the sound of a whistle
and I wanted to use
that to help us,
as the audience,
to connect with an animal
that's often portrayed
as strange and alien-like.
At this moment,
the mother octopus
is shown blowing on the eggs
to keep them alive
and I introduce a tremolo
of textural-type-strings
to mimic this airy quality.
Again, we hear the whistle,
almost as a call from the
mother to her babies saying
"It's time to hatch."
Using a frenzy of pumping
heart-like synths,
I match stylized editing,
as we are provided
with a glimpse
into what could be
this baby octopus's future
if they survive.
We now get our
baby octopus's theme
for the first time.
It begins with a simple
waltz-like motive
on an electric piano.
I found inspiration
in the gentle,
pulsing motion of
the baby octopuses
as if they drift
through the ocean currents.
Almost like
choreographing a dance.
I build on this with the
return of our lone whistle.
Across this episode,
we follow
this giant pacific octopus
from hatching to adulthood
and I wanted to give her
this distinct sound state
that we could recognise
each time
we return to her story.
We learn that once hatched,
a giant pacific octopus
never sees her mother again.
So I looked at this moment
almost as a goodbye song,
from a mother to her child,
as we witness one cycle
of life nears its end
and another begins.
Quiet swells of choir
and strings gently expand
and become large in scope
as our baby octopus
makes her way into the vast
ocean for the first time.
The scene ends back
in our simple waltz-motive,
reminding us that this
is but one octopus's journey
in this large ocean.